[Music]
shane is with us shane is in
indianapolis hi shane how are you
hey dave i'm doing well how about
yourself better than we deserve what's
up
well great um my wife and i are seeing a
move in the next one to three years
um i'm debt free other than my house i
owe 115 000 on on the house right now
and i have 125 000 in cash and then i
also have twenty thousand dollars of an
emergency fund
um
do i
think so i wonder just do i pay out the
house now or
knowing that we're probably going to
move you know in the next one to three
years do i continue on the path that i'm
on and just stacking away cash or i'll
pay it off and then you can stack more
cash because you don't have a house
payment yeah
yep okay
that's impressive
how did you save up 125 000 i'm just
curious
um
we just kind of had a wildly important
goal of my my wife staying at home and
we thought the best path
of doing this um
you know is to pay off the house and to
remain debt free so
early on we started off
we took your financial peace university
before we got married and we've kind of
uh just always
lived by your rules and principles
you're doing extremely well i'm very
proud of you let's back into why i said
to do that okay
you're gonna move anyway obviously
you know that when you sell the house
they're gonna give you a check so you're
not losing the money you're not spending
the money you're not consuming the money
it's just changing positions
which asset it's parked in right and so
you're doing away with
a mortgage and your interest rate is
higher than your savings rate on your
savings account
so you're mathematically going to win a
tiny tiny bit there but it's not really
worth doing it for that what will happen
is this and this is what i it took me
probably
15 or 20 years of doing this before i
really gave credit to this because i'm a
math nerd i wanted everything to be a
math thing
but here's a weird thing you make biff
different decisions with a paid for
house
yeah
you just do because you're your head
space you're where you are spiritually
where you are relationally changes
and so i'm not saying you'll stay
because it's paid for
i'm saying you're going to kind of feel
um
very confident edging on cocky as a
seller
because i don't have to sell it
and uh i'm you know i'm gonna get a
price and there's nothing pushing this
there's no there's no uh i just don't
have to be in a hurry because i don't
have any payments
also you're going to be able to pile up
cash like a crazy man because you don't
have the house payment anymore that
works too
and you're obviously very good at that
congratulations again i'm very
impressive uh but but
you know even stuff like uh you know
another wave of covid comes through or
uh
or just a wave of political stupidity
comes through which seems to be coming
in the tsunami level these days but the
uh uh but you know if you just keep this
you know something comes through all
these external variables that we don't
have control over
our spirits and our decision-making
is much cleaner and wiser when we're
sitting in a paid for house
than when we're sitting with a hundred
and fifteen thousand hundred twenty
thousand in the bank and not a paid for
house it's just weird and it does it's
there's no math to it it's just a the
borrower is slave to the lender and the
slave when he no longer has a master is
known as free
and it just you know think about
a slave and how their mentality changes
and that's a
there is something to that that is
beyond just the apparent mathematics
yeah absolutely and not only that but
you're saving on interest you're going
to pay to this bank you're freeing up
the payment and you said at the
beginning you have this wildly important
goal so that your wife can stay home and
so if you can do that earlier now with a
paid for house this is fantastic news
well she's probably already done it i
mean it's just
incredible very very well done sharp
young couple and i'm glad that uh what
we do at ramsey was able to add value to
somebody like that's life yeah very more
of that i want to see that happen all
over the yeah i mean what problems to
have i have the money in the bank to pay
off my house should i do it this is a
there's a better much better question
than i'm four payments behind yes how do
i stop the foreclosure yeah because we
have done detailed research and 100 of
the foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage iron-clad data it's just
straight up there's no question about it
so there is risk associated with it and
we just do not perceive the risk because
we all understand that housing is such a
good investment real estate's such a
stable investment by and large
and so we don't assign any emotionally
and spiritually any risk to the process
now shane wasn't pushing back but some
of your you know
dave ramsey lost his mind he told that
32 year old guy pay off his house he
should have been telling me no no dave's
not lost his mind
the
instructions i gave him were the
shortest distance between where he is
now and wealthy
and we know this from the millionaire
data yeah and we're seeing this where a
lot of people have a stack of cash and
they go well dave it doesn't make sense
to pay off the house i could invest that
the market's doing so well right now it
is but those people have never felt the
feeling of having a paid for house
without mortgage payment
and here's the thing too if you don't
think there's an emotional element to it
just reverse the process
what if you were sitting with um
ten thousand dollars in the bank instead
of 125 000
and your house was paid for
would you go borrow
115 on your house in order to put
it in the bank and have 125 in the bank
with a mortgage
reverse the process
and i bet i mean i i would say 98 of the
time i ask the question in reverse like
that people just go well no
but it's a trick question because it
tricks you to thinking with your heart
not just your head and your heart's
where you measure risk your math where
you do math oh that was good your head's
where you do math your heart's where you
measure risk and you just kind of you
have an almost a visceral reaction to
that no i wouldn't do that
but well it's the same thing yeah you
get excited about seeing that money grow
in an investment but you don't take into
account the risk when you do that but
when you talk about borrowing money on a
paid for house you feel the risk
for the first time yeah all of a sudden
all of your
end quotes air quotes sophisticated math
goes out the window yep yeah i say air
quotes because it's not sophisticated
because you left out risk and
sophisticated math would include risk
this is the ramsey show